-Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
And I'm so pleased to welcome
you to the annual Robert
and Maurine Rothschild Lecture.
The Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study
is dedicated to fostering
inquiry that transcends
disciplinary boundaries.
It is also uniquely
committed to sharing
the fruits of advanced study
with a broad public audience.
The calendar card that you'll
find on your chairs today,
lists a number of
compelling upcoming events.
And I hope you'll join
us for some of them.
I especially draw your
attention to the annual Phelps
Lecture in the Creative Arts.
It will be held on Monday,
October 19, when current fellow
and choreographer,
Karole Armitage,
will discuss how dance makes
meaning through movement rather
than words.
I also want you to be
among the very first
to know about an
event coming in April.
The Center for African Studies,
the American Repertory Theatre,
the new Harvard undergraduate
concentration in Theater Dance
and Media, and the
Radcliffe Institute,
will collaborate to
mount a production
of Here Word, a dramatic
commentary on gender
and contemporary Nigerian
society, written and directed
by Nigerian playwright, Ifeoma
Fafunwa, a play that has never
before been performed
in the United States.
But today, the Radcliffe--
the Rothschild Lecture.
For the past 25 years
the Rothschild Lecture
has epitomized the deepest
purposes of Radcliffe.
Harvard alumnus Bob Rothschild
and the late Maurine Rothschild
was a college, Radcliffe
College alumna and trustee,
established the Rothschild
Lecture at the Schlesinger
Library in 1990 in honor
of their 50th reunions.
It has brought to Radcliffe
yard, visionary leaders who
straddled the worlds of
academia and public life.
And it has become
one of the key ways
that we have advanced the public
side of the Schlesinger Library
and of Radcliffe.
These purposes have
mattered deeply
to Bob, who is truly a
Renaissance man, a business
executive, a biographer of
an 18th century astronomer,
a serious art collector,
an accomplished sailor,
and a generous
university citizen who
has a long history of
support for Radcliffe.
And his partner in
this mission, has
been Radcliffe graduate and
Bob's wife, Margaret Touborg
Rothschild, whose staunch
championship of women's rights
has helped keep this
lecture series so dynamic.
For a quarter of a century
the Rothschild's generosity
has allowed us to learn from
leading figures like Anita
Hill, Barbara Ehrenreich,
[? Marcia Sen, ?] Gail Collins,
and Samantha Power.
Bob is not able to be with
us here this afternoon
for health reasons.
But I know that the good
vibes will reach him.
So please join me in
thanking Bob and Margaret
for this wonderful gift of
an inspiring lecture series.
I'm so pleased to have
you all here today
to mark this milestone with us.
And I hope you will stay for a
reception immediately following
the lecture, which will
be held in Fay House,
directly next door.
In addition to the
Rothschild's, we
are also honored to have with
us this evening Radcliffe
medallist and former Chief
Justice of the Massachusetts
Supreme Judicial Court,
Margaret Marshall.
Today's lecture not only
celebrates the 25th anniversary
of the Rothschild
Lectures, it also
marks the first
Schlesinger Library event
under the leadership
of the new Carl
and Lily Pfortzheimer
Foundation, Director
of the Schlesinger Library,
Professor Jane Kamensky.
Along with being a
prominent historian
of early American history,
Jane is a Radcliffe veteran
in her own right.
She was a Radcliffe
Institute fellow in 2006-07
and a Bunting Institute
fellow a decade before that.
I look forward eagerly to
working with Jane to further
develop, diversify,
and digitize,
the libraries
outstanding collections,
and to enrich the relationship
between the library
and the rest of
Radcliffe, in ways
that continue to make the
Radcliffe Institute more
than the sum of its parts.
So welcome Jane.
It's a very big day here.
And for all these reasons,
it was even more important
than usual to invite an
especially inspiring speaker.
We wanted someone
whose life and work
embodied both the
spirit of the Rothschild
Lecture and the Schlesinger
Libraries dedication
to documenting the
multi-dimensional lives
of women, a tall order.
In January 2013, I was fortunate
to have the opportunity
to visit South Africa.
I was so profoundly moved by
what I learned and saw there
that I returned determined that
the Radcliffe Institute would
play a role in deepening
understanding in the United
States of this fascinating,
complex, and inspiring nation.
I learned a lot about Dr.
Mamphela Ramphele while
in South Africa.
And I was delighted to
discover, upon my return,
that she and the
Radcliffe Institute
shares some very good friends,
including Margaret Touborg
Rothschild and Margaret
Marshall, who was born
and raised in South Africa.
In fact, when Matina Horner
was the President of Radcliffe
College, Margaret
Touborg Rothschild
worked to bring Dr. Ramphele to
Radcliffe as a Bunting Fellow.
A tale of two Margaret's.
One Matina and one Mamphela,
it was over-determined
that we would invite
Dr. Ramphele to speak.
She honors us today by sharing
her insights into the question,
Can African women redefine
liberation for all?
I will turn to Jane to give
a full introduction to Dr.
Ramphele in just a moment.
But before I do, I want
to pause for a moment
to consider her experience as
a Bunting Fellow in 1988-89,
when she wrote about
place, power, and South
African migrant workers.
She also used her
time here to reflect
on the purposes of
scholarship, as she
explains in her
marvellous autobiography.
It was here that she began
to search for ways to ensure
that her academic work
would not distract
from her political
commitments, but rather serve
and I quote her,
"as a continuation
of her previous work
as an agent of change."
End quote.
And she has certainly
found ways to do that.
As a medical doctor
and an anthropologist,
she has found the parallels
between the participant
observer in the activist
and the anthropologist.
She listens to people
in their own voices.
She sees the world
from perspectives
other than her own.
She has helped to create an
anthropology of South Africa
that moves far beyond in
her words, "the handmaiden
of colonialism," to building
much deeper understanding
of South African society.
And in doing that,
she has insisted
on the importance of
gender alongside race
as a fundamental
category of analysis.
As a change maker and
a scholar of change,
she has demonstrated the
courage to take risks
and to rise to what she
so beautifully identifies
as "the enormous challenge,
to remain human."
Let me now welcome
to the lectern
my new colleague in the
Harvard History Department
and the Radcliffe
Institute, Jane Kamensky,
who will give Dr. Ramphele
a fuller introduction.
Jane.
-It's a great honor as the
brand new Faculty Director
of the Schlesinger Library to
welcome Dr. Mamphela Ramphele
back to Radcliffe
and to introduce her
to you on the auspicious
occasion of this afternoon's
25th annual Rothschild Lecture.
The Schlesinger is
a premier repository
of the papers
documenting the lives
and works of American
women, especially
the leaders of the
more than century
long feminist freedom
struggle in the United States.
So it seems particularly fitting
that we hear this afternoon
from one of the most important,
original voices in the struggle
for the liberation of South
Africa from apartheid's
and in the fight for the
freedom of African women.
Battles that Dr. Ramphele has
waged for nearly five decades
and in which she
continues to manage
the delicate work of
breaking boundaries
while building bridges.
If you have not already
read Dr. Ramphele's
marvellous autobiography, My
Life, a Passion for Freedom,
I recommend that you do so
immediately after the lecture.
The book traces the dawning
of a political consciousness
that proceeded the headlines
for which she is well known.
She was born in the
Northern Transvaal
in 1947, a year
before the apartheid
state took its full legal form.
Both of her parents
were teachers
and nurtured the
passion for learning
that drove Ramphele to
complete her medical training
at the University
of Natal, which
was a highly unusual path for
a woman of her place and time,
let alone a woman of color.
Much of the credit for this
and subsequent accomplishments
goes to Dr. Ramphele's grit.
Hers is a story of
perseverance in the face
of unbelievable
obstacles, including
law and brute military force.
But Ramphele as she
tells her story embeds
her life in a web of lineage
as much as individual striving.
And particularly
important to that
web were the generations of
strong women who preceded her.
Her mother she
writes, "faithfully
fulfilled her responsibilities
as a newly married young woman
in the village, but she would
not be bullied by anyone."
Dr. Ramphele's own biography
shows the deep imprint
of that maternal legacy
and her commitment
to passing it on to others.
If Dr. Ramphele's
life work reminds us
that people shape history,
it is also a tale of the way
that history makes the
people who live through it.
Hers is, in part,
a story of timing.
She writes,
"Historical accidents
give rise to major tides,
which sweep the unwary aside
or redirect them into
paths that they could not
have anticipated."
She was not unwary.
She entered medical school
in 1968, a year of rage
and hope and change
all over the globe.
Along with Stephen Biko
and several others,
Ramphele was a founding member
of the Black Consciousness
Movement, the powerful
South African strand
of the global
struggle for freedom
of oppressed peoples of color.
She recalls herself and Biko
and their cohorts staying up
at night talking politics,
reading Gandhi and listening
to the voices of Malcolm X and
Martin Luther King on tape.
America's civil rights
movement infused their struggle
against apartheid, just as the
South African freedom struggle
would reignite campus
activism in the United States
in the late 1970s and 1980s.
For many of those
years, Ramphele
suffered cruelly under
the apartheid regime,
detained under the Terrorism
Act in the wake of the Soweto
uprisings and then banished
to remote [INAUDIBLE].
Yet, she managed not only to
endure there but to build,
establishing community health
programs and other initiatives
especially directed at the
empowerment of rural women.
As apartheid crumbled, she rose.
She furthered her already
considerable education
earning advanced degrees in
Public Health and Tropical
Medicine at the University
of Witwatersrand.
And by the time
South Africa held
its first democratic elections
in the spring of 1994,
she had earned her PhD
in Social Anthropology
from the University
of Cape Town.
Those historical
elections took place
while she was on
sabbatical at Harvard.
She cast the first
vote of her life
beneath the golden dome
of Bulfinch's State House,
here in Boston.
In the two decades since
that historical vote,
Dr. Ramphele has deepened
her impact in South Africa
and extended her reach
around the globe.
In 1996, she was appointed Vice
Chancellor of the University
of Cape Town, an
attainment, she describes,
as beyond her wildest
dreams, and certainly
beyond the historical
imagination of the world
in which she was born and
which she helped to change.
In the year 2000, she became
one of the managing directors
of the World Bank, the
first South African
to hold that position.
She has been a force for social
justice in the global economy
and within the contentious
political landscape
of the new South Africa.
In February 2013, she launched
a political party, Agang,
dedicated to quote "True
freedom for all, a job, a home,
and a life of dignity."
She stepped down from
her leadership of Agang
last year retiring to the
life of an active citizen.
Although, I have a
feeling that retirement
is probably the softer of those
terms and active the louder.
She continues fully to
embody the highest promises
of global citizenship, not
least through the telling
of her remarkable story.
One had to write history to
make history, Dr. Ramphele says.
Emphasizing, in her
autobiography, the importance
of scholars, storytellers,
archives, and archivists
to the freedom struggle.
Quote, "Storytelling is
a historical imperative.
We cannot successfully navigate
uncharted waters without some
script to guide us.
This is particularly
so for women,"
she says, "especially
black women.
Women have to find a script,
a narrative to live by,
because all other scripts
are likely to depict them
in roles that fit the
conventional stereotypes."
There is nothing conventional
or stereotypical about the life
and work of Dr.
Mamphela Ramphele.
The title of her
talk this afternoon
is, Can African Women
Redefine Liberation for All?
She demonstrates in
everything she does,
but the answer
emphatically is yes.
Dr. Ramphele.
-Good afternoon.
I can't tell you what an
honor it is and what a joy
it is to be back here at a
place which shaped my engagement
in the academic world.
At that time, I came
as a Bunting Scholar.
And as already said,
Margaret, was the moving force
behind that.
I have to thank Radcliffe
for bringing me back
and for reminding
me of the beauty
and the historical importance
of now the Radcliffe
Institute for advanced studies.
My little encounter with the
students during lunch time
today convinces me that
you're doing a fabulous job.
It is 27 years ago
that I was here.
And in some ways it
feels like yesterday.
But a lot has happened still.
So I would like to spend
the rest of this afternoon
exploring with you this question
that is the title of my talk.
I'm not so sure about
the self evident part.
But I do believe that we need
to ask these tough questions.
But to do so, I want us to
listen, as a starting point,
to the voice of a
17-year-old African women.
Here is what she said,
"Navigating a world in which we
women fight to be
free in thought,
in speech, in actions, is
thrilling, as it is vexing.
Yet, it is precisely
this complex balance
between deep hardships
and intoxicating victories
in becoming a woman
that I'm realizing
an extraordinary power.
To be made to feel threatened,
I have come to realize,
that I am in fact
extremely threatening.
We women no longer
know our place.
know our place."
I want you to hold
that in your mind
as we go back to sketching
the context in which
this young woman said
these amazing words
for a 17-year-old.
We live in a world in which
knowledge, systems, technology,
tools, and resources
are available to address
any major challenge that we
face in our global world today.
But we seem to lack the
wisdom to govern our affairs
for the benefit of all citizens.
My own country, South Africa,
and the continent of Africa,
are the poster children of
the gap between resources
and opportunity to
succeed on one hand,
and the real and lived
reality of the indignity
of poverty and
hopelessness affecting
most citizens on the earth.
This gap reflects the cost
of living with old minds,
and failing to adapt
to the new world.
South Africa's Constitution is
the envy of many in the world.
But the lived reality
of many of these people
is still shaped by inequities
and human indignities.
The triple burden of poverty,
unemployment, and inequality
weigh heavily on the majority
of South Africa's people
remains color-coded
and gendered.
Just over 64% of
women are unemployed.
And of those employed, few
make it to senior positions
or to board positions,
whether your
looking at the private
or the public sector.
Pay parity remains
unattained at many levels
in both public and
private sectors.
Only 25% of business
owners are women.
And 42% of
entrepreneurs are women.
Black African women,
the majority population
in South Africa and in
Africa, bare the brunt
of the triple burden of poverty,
unemployment, and inequality.
Africa is home to eight of the
10 countries in the world today
with the youngest populations.
The proportion of
those below 25 years
averages 67% in my continent.
Ironically, Africa is also led
by some of the oldest living
heads of state, with Uncle Bob--
not your Bob-- Uncle Bob Mugabe
of Zimbabwe leading the pack.
They are 10 years in office,
average 10 to 35 years,
placing them among
the oldest living
heads of states in the world.
The disjunction between
a youthful population
that is majority women,
being led by old men
speaks to the old mindset
that needs to be challenged.
The question I would like to
explore in this talk today,
is related to this context.
Can African women redefine
freedom for the benefit of all?
If so what would it take
to redefine freedom?
How different would
such freedom be
from the post-colonial and
post-apartheid experience
freedom today?
What values, what
systems, what practices,
would characterize freedom
for all as a lived experience?
You may well ask, why focus on
African women as change agents?
History teaches us
that change only
comes when those who
stand to benefit most
stand up and make it happen.
The redefinition
of freedom is most
likely to be done by those who
suffer oppression most and are
conscious of their agency
to bring about change.
The persistence of a
narrative of freedom
that excludes such change
agents becomes, in this case,
a motivating force.
Slavery ended when slaves stood
up and challenged their slave
masters.
Colonialism ended
when subjugated people
stood up and refused to
be treated as second class
citizens in the
land of their birth.
Apartheid ended when
black people, led
by young black people, stood
up and redefined themselves
as free from the label
of being Non-white,
Non-European in Africa.
Imagine.
And we declared
ourselves black and free.
Post-colonial Africa is
under-performing its potential
to become a thriving, inclusive,
economic, democratic space,
that leverages the huge
resources, whether you're
looking at the natural
resources, mineral
resources, or humans resources.
This under-performance
results from the failure
to utilize the talents and
capabilities of all of Africa's
people-- men and women.
Africa's narrative of freedom is
that of male liberation heroes
claiming leadership of
their independent countries
as an entitlement and their
reward for their contributions
to the liberation struggle.
Many have failed to
make the transition
from freedom fighters whose
allegiance to the movements
takes precedence
over everything else.
They failed to become
public servants
accountable to all
citizens and respectful
of their human dignity.
It is no accident that
these liberation heroes
are all male modeling themselves
on male dominated power-ides
in the rest of the world.
One needs only look at
any global gathering.
Global leaders are mostly men,
with the notable exceptions
of Angela Merkel, the
Chancellor in Germany at EU
level, President Dilma Rouseff
in Brazil at the brics level,
and the singleton African woman
President Ellen Johnson-Sirleaf
of Liberia at the AU level.
This is the performance
of the world we live in.
Constitutional guarantees of
gender equality and protection
of human rights, that grace
many countries' legal systems,
have yet to become
the lived reality
for most African citizens.
Gender discrimination, gender
based violence and abuse,
conspired to undermine women
and children, in most countries.
The dominant narrative in Africa
is that of liberation heroes
and their parties being entitled
to govern-- no more accurate--
entitled to rule and perpetrate.
In my country, we've got
a president who says,
the [INAUDIBLE] will rule
until Jesus Christ comes.
He may just be surprised
that Jesus Christ comes
sooner than he is prepared.
Any criticism of
governing parties
is regarded as disloyal
[INAUDIBLE] liberators
and he's often heavily
punished through
socio-economic marginalization
threats and reality
of violence and intimidation.
The threat of punishment
for disloyalty to the ruling
party, strikes
fear in the hearts
of entrepreneurs, professionals,
and ordinary people alike.
Compliers becomes seen
as the only option
for many of those who choose to
remain in their home countries.
Immigration has also come to
be seen as an option for those
who can go to greener pastures.
And this has resulted
in Africa being deprived
of the skills, the creativity,
of millions of its citizens,
due to these
marginalizing tendencies
of our African governments.
We live the stories we tell,
and are told about ourselves.
Africa will remain captive to
unaccountable, self-serving
political leaders until such
time that citizens weave
and embrace a new narrative.
African women are
in a strong position
to weave a new narrative.
Women's positions as mothers,
sisters, grandmothers,
and care-givers, puts them
in their strategic position
to tell stories that shape
the lives of the many people
that they touch.
Women's traditional
storytelling, as a role,
has sustained
generations of Africans
and emboldened them through
folktales, praise songs,
and other formats.
These stories tell of their
greatness as a people.
And tells of the rich
heritage that is theirs.
It is time for women to
draw on this rich heritage.
It is time for African women to
ask the question with no name.
Remember, Betty Friedan, asked
in 1963, in a groundbreaking
book, The Feminine Mystique,
Friedan enabled women
to ask what they had all
along forbidden themselves
to confront, Is this all?
Friedan wove together the
threads of the many stories
that American women had not
given themselves the permission
to tell one another.
These woven stories helped to
end the captivity of silence.
Women rediscovered the
power within themselves
to be shapers of
their own futures,
thereby transcending the
then dominant narrative.
The birth of the second
wave of American feminism
took the courage of one
woman, Betty Friedan,
to mobilize us to
break their silence
and demand more of life.
African women, as this young
woman that I started with,
are increasingly asking, Is this
all that freedom means for us?
Is this all that freedom
means for our children
and our grandchildren?
Is this all that freedom means
for African men and women?
Is this all that our sons,
and daughters, and brothers,
and husbands, and
sisters, mothers, aunts,
sacrifice their lives for in
the struggle for liberation.
The answers to these
questions are the threads
of a new narrative that
African women are beginning
to weave with growing urges.
Black women writers, according
to an analyst that I quote,
"Committed to
historical intervention
and national reinvention
situating themselves
as new women of a new
Africa, more assertive, more
complex than their mothers, but
still connected with the past
and situated within
the family lineage
of female storytellers."
African women do
not have the luxury
of weaving exclusionary
feminist narratives.
Their circumstances
demand that they
weave an inclusive narrative.
Theirs is a narrative
that is framed
by their womanhood, their
humanity, their citizenship,
and their inter-generational
responsibilities.
Inclusive narrative of freedom
affirm the truism that one
cannot be free in an
unfree environment,
where others are unfree.
An inclusive freedom narrative
embraces the liberation of all,
from racism, sexism,
ageism, poverty,
and the indignity of inequality.
So what will it take
to redefine freedom?
Albert Camus, a twentieth
century French philosopher,
has got wise words in
answer to this question.
And I quote, "The only way
to deal with an unfree world
is to be so absolutely free
that your very existence is
an act of rebellion."
True freedom challenges the
dominant masculinity narrative,
that has held the world and
Africa captive for so long.
Masculinity framed by
an alpha male narrative
celebrates dominance.
The element constituting
this dominant masculinity
are anchored on
power and control.
The story goes, real men have
money and control over issues.
They occupy leadership
positions in public life,
flaunt their sexual prowess,
are hardy and boastful
of their intellectual
superiority.
This dominant masculinity
model operates
on a competitive "winner
takes all" model of power.
Such an approach to
gender relationships
undermines those men who
are defined as losers.
The alpha male dominance
model is sustained
by undermining other males.
Men who are unable to live up
to the expectations of the alpha
male narrative suffer from
an inferiority complex.
The sense of worthlessness
drives many men caught up
in this undermining system to
aggression and substance abuse.
The vicious cycle
of low self esteem,
feeling disrespected, and unable
to communicate inner fears
and hopes, drives the epidemic
of domestic violence and gender
violence against
women and children.
How can African women be
absolutely free in such
an unfree environment?
How can they make their very
existence an act of rebellion?
Such absolute
freedom can only come
from drawing on the goddesses
within the women themselves.
The goddess within each
woman is the expression
of love for the self, love
for those close to one,
and love for humanity.
The exercise of love in this
manner unleashes a live force
but leads us to a place
closest to the source
of our very being.
African women through their
struggles in an unfree world
are sustained by the all
embracing love as a life force.
They draw their energy from
narratives framed by Ubuntu
as we say in my home town.
That Ubuntu mirrors universally
recognized feminine principles
that are set out in a book, if
you haven't seen it, called,
Athena Doctrine, written by me.
These principles are
connectedness, humility,
candor, patience, empathy,
trustworthy, openness,
and flexibility.
These principles
anchor the values
that stand in
contradiction to those
of the current
dominant male model.
These transformative
values frame
the nature of the rebellion
we're talking about.
That women waged that
rebellion in both the private
and the public spaces
that they occupy,
to challenge traditional
conduct of relationships
between men and women.
African women engaged in
such acts of rebellion
in an unfree world need
to increasingly draw
on the strength of fellow
women within supportive circles
so they can succeed together.
Such circles need to operate
at the personal and domestic
level, at the
community level, with
any institutional settings,
and professional settings,
at work, at places of worship,
and in the wider society.
So [INAUDIBLE] circles and
networks of support for women,
we have to weave within
them to go across
the boundaries of race, of
class, of age, of culture.
And this is essential to the
development and sustenance
of a momentum for
transformative change.
In my work with my colleagues in
my home country in the Eastern
Cape, we draw on the
strengths and tools
of the traditional African
conversational circle
to drive transformation.
These conversational
circles enable participate
in communities of men and
women to empower themselves
in one another.
Letsema, which is
what we call them.
Letsema means collaboration.
The Letsema circle they evoke
the egalitarianism, the trust
building and the
collaborative principles
that traditional
African societies
used to use to affirm
and to work together
to take out common challenges.
And in doing so, they protect
themselves, as well as
those who are still to
come in future generations.
The symbolic power of
circles of conversations
enable individuals to
look inside themselves
to claim their space, find
their voice, and link with us.
In a circle there is
no chair or somebody
who's above somebody else.
We are all the same and
we make eye contact.
And that's the
affirmation that we need.
Our experience in
this Letsema work
confirms the
importance of raising
the consciousness of individuals
of the power of the lives
within themselves.
They become their
own liberators.
The life force
within them enable
them to reach out to others
to sustain acts of rebellion
against forces that
hold them captive.
Women who are more attentive to
that inner space where the life
source pulsates
and the main actors
and leaders in this inner circle
and in team that is driving us.
I was excited earlier
this year to discover
the work of Jean
Shinoda Bolen that
resonates with our work
in this inner circle.
"Women's circles
form one at a time,"
writes Jean, whose
also a union analyst.
"Each circle expands
the experience
of being in one to more women.
Each women in every circle
who is changed by it
takes this experience into
her world of relationships.
Until, one fine day, a
new circle will form,
and it will be the
millionth circle-- the one
that tips the
scales-- and brings us
into the post-patriarchal
human era."
Imagine that.
Using experience gleaned from
Jean's participation in women's
circles since
1985, she argues is
that these support groups,
learning societies, agents
of change, can empower members.
The author begins by casting a
circle, who, want, when, where.
And then moves to centering the
group with common intention,
with energy,
compassion and wisdom.
Two important criteria to
keep those circles alive,
equality and make sure
that everyone feels safe.
Jean concludes with an
overview of the importance
of rituals and celebration
in women's circles.
It is in the loving
embrace of the circle,
that more and more women
can and are living out
their lives of rebellion
and changing the world one
step at a time.
So what would an Africa with
redefined freedom look like?
We now know, for
sure, that equality
is good for everyone,
rich and poor.
The authors of The Spirit
Level, present a persuasive case
that more equitable
societies are healthier,
have longer life expectancies,
experience less crime,
and in security.
And they reap benefits
of the talents and skills
of all their people.
And they ascribe
this to the trust
that develops in a more
equal society, which
is a marker of how with
greater material equality
you can help to create a more
cohesive corporate community
to the benefit of everybody.
You only need to look at
Scandinavia and Japan--
even though on the gender
side you may have some issues.
We also know from recent
analysis by Thomas Piketty
that wealth accumulation
has over the ages
largely favored property owners
and inheritance of money.
Of course, in the
twenty-first century
technology advances has
created new business and so on.
But at the end of
the day, capital
begets more capital
accumulation.
And the majority of the
inheritors of wealth are, men.
What is the clear
is that societies
that have succeeded
in overcoming
the burden off the triple
burden of poverty, unemployment,
and inequality, have focused
on investing in the development
of talent in all citizens.
Instituting taxation systems
that enlarge the common pool
and equalize the benefits
of development for all
is essential.
There is a special case to
be made for gender equality
beyond economics.
Gender equality questions lie
at the heart of the personal
being political.
Gender relationships while
being intensity intimate,
are heavily framed and
governed by cultural values
and reflect how and
who exercise power
in what spaces and [INAUDIBLE].
The exercise of power
is a political process
with political consequences
beyond the space in which
the micro processes play out.
The transformation of
gender relationships
from the African patriarchal
toxic alpha male dominance
model, with it's
inherent violence,
is essential to the
redefinition of freedom for all.
Men, including the
alpha male, who
lives in terror of losing
control and dominance,
have to sustain their status
by whatever means available,
including violence.
Such men, both
dominater and dominated,
cannot be fully who they
have the potential to become.
They are too encumbered
by the burden
of maintaining dominance or
surviving being dominated
to experience the joy of
absolute freedom and enjoyment
of relationships
of mutual support
and nurture that only
true freedom can bring.
African women as
storytellers, need
to weave an empowering
narrative of transformed gender
relationships.
And the opportunities
that stem from that
in the personal,
the professional,
and the political spaces
within which they operate.
True freedom is
experienced where power
is regarded as an enabler.
The more people are enabled
to shape their own futures,
the more energy
would flow in society
to unleash talent,
creativity, and innovation.
Societies that have
greater freedom for all,
especially for women and
girls, do much better
than those characterized
by domination
of men over women and rich
people over poor people.
The new narrative being
woven is putting Ubuntu,
the I am, because you
are, as the governing
principle in traditional
African societies,
is being used as a powerful
force that can draw strength.
We can draw strength from it.
It is an anchor in
interpersonal relationships,
in community relationships,
in which one's humanity is
affirmed and confirmed
through those relationships.
One becomes a better
person by being continually
conscious of the nurturing
and empowering affirmations
of reciprocal relationships.
Ubuntu resonates with
similar principles
in other cultures such as the
Japanese and Celtic traditions.
The Celtic view is
particularly powerful.
Just let me quote this, "The
human body is born compete.
In one moment."
You don't leave your
hand inside it comes out.
"The human heart is
never completely born.
It is being birthed in every
experience of your life.
Everything that happens
to you has the potential
to deepen you."
So.
One is only complete as fully
human by experiences of life
and along sides of a human race.
African women need solidarity
circles and networks
to draw on this on-going
birthing process
towards becoming more fully
human within relationships
that are nourished by
the life force of love
for self and others.
The difficult task of not
only liberating themselves
from the stranglehold
of patriarchal systems
and the zero sum
approaches to power.
It's tough enough to
do that, but women also
have to liberate their men
because without everyone being
free, no one can be truly free.
And that can only
be accomplished
as acts of love for humanity.
Unfree, fearful men
are the main drivers
of domestic violence and gender
based violence in our streets,
in our villages,
in the work place.
And for as long as
these men remain trapped
in this toxic masculinity
and patriarchal system,
African politics and the
development of Africa
will be held captive.
Sindiwe Magona, an award-winning
author in my country,
is also a survivor of two failed
marriages and the inequities
of apartheid, is one of the
committed transformative
storytellers.
She has decided, she
told me the other day,
to rewrite history from the
lens of a black African woman.
In order to, in her
words, "re-shape selves,
communities and societies--
when all are categories
of sense-making are
open to re-definition."
Magona's elegant execution
of this commitment
finds poignant expression in her
novel, called, Beauty's Gift.
If you haven't read it,
I would recommend it.
This novel transforms an African
woman dying of HIV/AIDS into,
in Magona's words, "a
self-government and
self-assured being,
ascended in her ability
to freely locate herself
in any environment
of her own creation.
Let me conclude.
I would like to end
where we started,
by making you listen
to the voices of women,
young women, who are
the leaders of today
and who are busy
re-defining freedom.
Here's one of them.
"My mother, and my
mother, and her mother,
we're amazing storytellers.
From them, I learned to
tell happy stories that
build a family,
community, and nation.
I learned that for my
life to be beautiful,
I have to tell beautiful
stories about it.
I grew up watching them and
drinking from their love, words
and wisdom.
I would like to see the
upcoming generation of girls who
sees so much love in
there formative years
from their mothers, their
grandmothers, and carers
so they do not have to seek
love and validation else where,
but be content with the
love they carry within.
I would like them not to have
invisible ceilings placed
in their life experiences
and career paths
by patriarchal systems,
but to be able to flourish
to their best ability."
Do you see why I'm so
optimistic about our future.
Thank you.